(thunder crashes)
- Jake, he accused you of murder
in a public forum.
- No one takes that seriously.
That's what kids do.
They just try to sound cool.
That's all it is. Honest.
- The book grew out of my
experiences as a prosecutor.
Mark preserved
the essence of the novel,
which is this isn't
a crime story about a family,
this is a family story
that happens to be
about a crime.
- They really think I killed Ben.
- It's a mistake.
We're gonna figure it out. Don't worry.
- For me, the fun
of being a screenwriter
is finding source
material and saying
what's the best cinematic
version of this story.
- What was so exciting was that
you could open the story up
to explore all of these possibilities
that series TV allows you to do.
- The first time Mark gave me
all the episodes,
I was like, all right,
I'll just read one tonight.
And, you know,
you get to the end
and you're, like, aah, I gotta
read the next one now.
- We have Morten Tyldum
directing all eight episodes,
so it really has a uniformity
of directorial vision.
- I loved working with Mark on this.
It was great to work very
closely together.
We knew exactly what
we liked, what we wanted to do.
- To see Morten work,
and realize how high the standards are,
explains how he's able to
achieve what he achieved on screen.
- 14, they already got him on murder.
You get to choose.
You can be a good man,
or you can be a good father.
- One of the challenges
in adapting it is that
I don't want it to be limited to
just Andy's perspective.
I want it to be Laurie's perspective,
Jacob's perspective.
- In doing adaptations,
you're not seeing it
through the eyes of the cops,
or the victim's.
You're actually seeing it
through this family.
- To have these incredibly
exciting actors,
who differ from
the characters in the book
with respect to their age
or their appearance, is wonderful.
- He didn't do this.
I know he didn't.
- No, you don't.
- No one can sustain that level
of deception.
- Of course, he could.
- Bill's book, and the show
even more so,
really tries to explore how dark
can you believe Jacob is,
and still hold on to
this glimmer of hope
that it's impossible
he could've done this.
- I didn't do it.
I swear.
- Do you know what's at stake?
Do you realize
what they want to do to you?
- Stop, you're scaring him!
- Good! He should be scared!
I'm scared!